AMEER ABBAS: Hello, and welcome.
My name is Ameer Abbas.
I'm a product manager at Google.
I focus on application and
platform modernization.
Last year I delivered
a presentation
with an eerily similar
topic to this one.
It was called "Building
Globally Scalable
Applications with Istio
and Anthos Service Mesh."
So you're probably
wondering why am I doing
the same presentation again.
Well, not quite.
I thought this year I would
take some of the foundations
and principles we
talked about last year
and put them into practice,
and I can show you
some of the practical
applications of delivering
modern applications.
So let's get started.
Let's talk about a service.
Everything revolves
around a service.
We build our teams, our
organizations, our engineering,
our product teams to deliver
beautiful, scalable, resilient
services to our customers.
Every service
needs a few things.
For instance, a service
needs to be resilient.
It needs to be scalable.
It needs to be secure.
And most importantly, it
needs to be manageable.
And what we mean by
that is by resiliency
I mean that we need
to be able to weather
the storms against any
infrastructure, human,
or machine error.
Scalability is pretty
self-explanatory.
We need to be able to run our
services on many computers,
maybe in many
Kubernetes clusters
in a lot of different
zones in many regions.
For security, we want to encrypt
all traffic, all communication
between services.
And we want to be able to
have the tools to implement
policy and enforce policy to
and from every single service.
And for manageability,
there's a lot
of things that fall
under that umbrella.
For instance, what do
we want to observe?
How do we want to
measure the signals?
How do we deliver traffic to
the right instance of a service?
And how do we reliably roll
out new versions of a service
and keep innovating and
manage the configuration that
revolves around a service?
All of that falls
under manageability.
So let's recap.
Last year we talked
about running services
in a single cluster.
Here we have a service
called front end
running in the front end
namespace with a pod.
And it's running in
a single cluster.
And everything is fine and dandy
until that cluster goes down.
And as soon as that
cluster goes down,
that service and
any other service
that's running in that cluster
also goes down with it.
So we've kind of
broken that first tenet
of resiliency, which
is that we can't even
weather the storms against
infrastructure failures.
So what do we do?
Well, we run our services
in more than one cluster.
So we run something called
distributed services.
A distributed service is
just a Kubernetes service
that runs on multiple clusters.
From an outsider's perspective,
it's the same logical service.
I don't need to know that it's
running on multiple clusters.
So here I have the
same service front
end running on four clusters.
On the left-hand side,
I have two clusters
in region 1 in two
different zones.
And on the right-hand
side, I have
two clusters in region 2
in two different zones.
So you can see that not only
do I have cluster resiliency,
I have zonal redundancy
and regional redundancy.
And what that means is
if my cluster goes down,
I still haven't lost my service.
I have three other clusters
that can serve traffic
for that service.
I can lose an entire region and
I have not lost that service.
I can lose multiple clusters
in multiple regions.
As long as that last
cluster has enough capacity
to serve traffic for
that particular service,
I'm good to go.
So you can already
see the effects
of scalability and
resiliency when
you run distributed services.
But with distributed services
comes a few considerations
that you may not consider
in a single cluster life.
For example, service
discovery and traffic routing.
In a single cluster, service
discovery and traffic routing
are kind of automatic.
When you drop a
service into a cluster,
it gets automatically
discovered.
Other services can get to it.
Routing just works.
So how do we do that in
a distributed service
environment?
Here we have two
distributed services.
What if the front
end service wants
to talk to the cart service?
How does the front
end service know
which pods are healthy
for the cart service?
Which pods to get to and
how to route to those pods.
So this is kind of the
east-west traffic problem.
Next is ingress.
Again in a single
cluster environment,
we have an ingress object.
We deploy the ingress
object, and we
can get traffic from outside
of the cluster to our service
no problem.
Well, how do we do that in
a multicluster environment?
How do we do a
multicluster ingress?
So this is the
multicluster ingress,
or the north-south problem.
And then when we bring
location into the mix,
things get a little
bit more complicated.
Here we have service running
on two different regions.
Let's say region 1 is in
Europe and region 2 is in Asia.
So the users that are in
Europe or closer to region 1,
we want to deliver their
traffic to an instance
of a service that's closer
to them, so in Europe.
And likewise, for the
users that are in Asia,
we want to deliver their traffic
to an instance of a service
that's running in Asia.
Only when something
goes wrong, for example,
let's say everything in
the Europe region is down,
now we want to send the
traffic from European users
over to the Asia user.
So how do we manage all of that?
And then, lastly, telemetry.
Again, in a single
cluster environment,
we have implementations
and tools
where we can measure
logging, and tracing,
and metrics for
every single service.
How do we do that in
a distributed service?
Which signals to measure?
How do we know if a
service is healthy?
What to alert on?
So all of those things
we're going to talk about,
and we're going to use
Anthos Service Mesh to solve
some of these things.
So let's go to the demo.
Let's get oriented
to the environment.
Here I have a Google Cloud
project with four GKE clusters
running.
GKE 1 and 2 are running
in region US West 2.
GKE 3 and 4 are running
in region US Central 1.
So it's the same four-cluster
model that we just saw.
Let's look at the
Workloads page.
I've deployed a few
sample applications.
And one of them is the
famous online boutique
retail application that
consists of 13 services.
I've deployed each service
in their own namespace,
and you can see by the workloads
that each service is deployed
as a distributed service.
So ad is running on
all four clusters.
Cart is running on
Shopfrontend, which is how
you access the application,
is also running on
all four clusters.
Let's take a closer look at
one of these deployments.
So we're going to look at
shopfrontend running in GKE 1.
And I'm going to
look at just the pods
for that particular one.
You can see that this pod
is running two containers.
One is the
shopfrontend container.
That's your actual
application container.
And the other one is
the asm sidecar proxy
called the istio-proxy.
Now, this proxy governs
the flow of traffic
to and from this
particular container.
And if we look at the
configuration of this proxy,
we can see what version
of asm we're running.
So in this case,
we're running 1.10.4,
which also correlates
to the Istio version.
We can also see that we're
using the Google-managed meshca
as our certificate authority.
We can also see that our
trust domain is the workload
identity for the project.
And I'm using the same trust
domain for all four clusters.
And that's how services
can talk and trust
each other across clusters.
What we want to do is we want to
look at from this istio-proxy's
perspective, how does
it view other services?
Let's quickly jump
into the terminal.
And I'm going to go ahead
into my GKE 1 cluster.
Let's look at the pods.
So kubectl get pods.
This is the same pod
that we were just
looking at in the console.
We're going to use the
istioctl CLI command.
And I just want to look
at the proxy-config.
And I just want to look at
the endpoints configuration
in the proxy-config for
this particular pod.
And instead of dumping
out the entire config,
I'm just going to grep it for
one of the services, which
is the cart service.
And here you can see
that from the perspective
of this shopfrontend
pod, it sees
that there are four
endpoints out there
that it can access when it
accesses the cart service.
These IP addresses
point to the pod
IP addresses of
the four endpoints.
Let's look at the pods.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is look at the pods
in the GKE 1 cluster
that's running in
shop-cart namespace.
So shop-cart namespace is where
the cart service is running.
And you can see that
in GKE 1 cluster
I only have one pod running with
the IP address of 10.0.2.11,
which is the same IP address
that you see up here,
which means that the other
three IP addresses correspond
to pods running in the
other three clusters.
And we can quickly
verify that by just
picking one other cluster,
for example, GKE 4.
And again, in GKE 4,
we're also just running
one cart pod with an IP
address of 10.8.2.143,
which is the IP address here.
So the asm control plane goes
out and discovers the endpoints
for every single
service and configures
every single istio-proxy
with those endpoints.
And that's how every single
service and every single pod
knows how to get to
every other service.
So that's how the service
discovery piece is working.
But we also want to make
sure that the traffic routing
east-west is working.
So for example, the
front end service
can talk to the cart service.
So in order to demo
that, it's best done
visually through a dashboard.
So here I have created a custom
dashboard for the cart service.
And this dashboard here
on the left-hand side,
I'm looking at
the request rates.
And I've grouped
them by location.
So I want to see who
is accessing the cart
service from which location.
And from the legend
here, you can
see that I'm receiving
requests to all four pods.
Further, I can group this by,
let's say, a source service,
source_canonical_service.
And here you can see that
there are only two services
accessing shop cart.
One is shopfrontend.
The other one is checkout.
And both services are
accessing all four locations.
And you can see that I have
a load generator that's
running that's showing me that
the traffic routing is working.
So in GKE, every pod can
talk to every other pod
if you have deployed
GKE in VPC native mode
as long as you have the
appropriate firewall rules.
So now east-west
traffic is working.
Next, let's take a look
at north-south traffic
and how ingress works.
So for that, let's go
back to our Clusters page.
And you'll notice that I have
this fifth cluster called
the ingress-config cluster.
This is the cluster
on how I configured
multicluster ingress.
Let's take a closer
look at this cluster.
So I'm going to go
back into my terminal.
I'm going to change my context
to the ingress-config cluster
and change my namespace
to istio-system.
Inside of the
istio-system namespace,
I have two resources.
I have a multicluster
ingress resource,
and I also have a
multicluster service resource.
And I have multiple
applications.
And that's why you
see a couple of these.
So the multicluster ingress
resource corresponds
to an ingress resource and a
multicluster service resource
corresponds to a
service resource,
just like you would
normally configure
an ingress and a service.
So let's take a closer
look at each of these.
So I'm going to look at the
multicluster ingress resource
first for the online boutique.
And you can see that
a multicluster ingress
resource looks a lot
like an ingress resource.
So I have a rule with a host.
So here's the host
of how I'm going
to access this application.
And its points back
to an app, a service.
But in this case,
instead of pointing back
to a Kubernetes service, it's
pointing back to a multicluster
service on port 80.
And if we look at the
multicluster service
resource that
corresponds to this,
again, it looks a lot like a
Kubernetes service resource.
So if we look at
especially the spec
of that particular
resource, you can
see that it has a
service name, a port,
and then most importantly,
it has this selector.
And what it's selecting is
the istio-ingressgateway
as the backend service.
The only difference here
is these cluster selectors.
And in this
particular case, I've
selected all four clusters.
So essentially what I've created
is the multicluster ingress.
You can think of it as the
front end that points back
to four different
backend services that
matches this selector, which
is the istio-ingressgateway
selector.
And what that creates, if
we go back to the console,
and I'm going to go
to Network Services,
Load Balancing is a front
end with four back ends.
So here if we just
look at these top two,
as a matter of fact, if
we look at the second load
balancer, which is the online
boutique, istio-mci, that got
created when we created
that MCI resource.
And it gave me a front end.
We'll talk about the
certificate here shortly.
But more importantly, we
have created four back ends.
And these four back
ends are pointing
to the istio-ingressgateway
service that's
running on all four clusters.
And we can verify that
by looking at the zone.
And you can see that all
four zones are covered.
And if we click on any
of these endpoints,
you can see the actual
pod IP addresses,
and then they are healthy.
If we go back to
this, the certificate,
I've created a Google managed
certificate for a DNS name.
So remember, in the
multicluster ingress,
we had a host field that
pointed to this DNS name.
And so in order to
access this service,
I can just simply copy this,
open a new tab, paste it,
and you can see that we can
access our online boutique
application.
And we can navigate
around this application.
So here I'm looking at
product description,
adding it to the cart.
Here I'm looking at
the cart service.
I can place the order, which
invokes the checkout service.
And you can see
all the functions
are working for that
particular application.
The way the actual
traffic flow is working
is when I access this
URL, if I scroll back,
I'm going to this
frontend IP address.
From this frontend, traffic
is being routed to one or more
of these istio-ingressgateway
backends.
And then the
istio-ingressgateway backend
routes the traffic
to the shopfrontend.
So the next thing is the
implication of locations.
So remember I have
istio-ingressgateway
running in two different regions
in four different clusters.
I also have the
shopfrontend running
in both of these regions
in all four clusters.
So what I want is if I'm
closer to US West 2 region,
I want to go to the US West
2 istio-ingressgateway,
and then eventually also to
the US West 2 shopfrontends.
So let's take a look at
how that is configured.
I'm going to go back into
Kubernetes workloads.
And I have a load
generator running
for the online boutique.
And you notice that my
load generator is only
running in the West 2 region.
And this is so I can show
you locality load balancing.
I also have locality load
balancing configured, but only
for the shopfrontend
application,
and the reason is just
for this demo purposes.
So let's go to the console.
Let's go to one of the
clusters, GKE 1, for example.
And I'm going to show you
the destination rule that's
running for the shopfrontend.
You can configure locality
load balancing mesh wide,
but I prefer to configure
it on a per service level.
So here I've configured it
just for the shopfrontend.
And the destination
rule determines
how the traffic is routed once
the routing decision is made.
And this is where you configure
locality load balancing.
So here in the load
balancer section
you can see that I have
locality load balancing enabled.
I also have a failover setting
which says go from US West
2 region to US Central 1,
since I'm looking at the GKE 1
configuration.
And then I also have
this outlier detection,
which determines when a
failover or a failure occurs.
This is a very aggressive rule
just for the sake of the demo.
Essentially, I'm
saying in every second,
even if I have a single error,
consider that an outage,
and eject that particular
deployment for a minute.
And so you can see that
just with the addition
of these 5-10 lines, I've
created locality load
balancing.
And I have the same
exact destination
rules for all four clusters
for the frontend service.
So in order to prove that
that is actually working,
remember that my load generator
is only running in US West 2.
So what I should expect
is only the West frontend
to be receiving traffic, because
nobody else is really accessing
this particular application.
So the best way to do that
is let's look at the charts.
So here I have a
custom dashboard
that I've created for
shopfrontend very similar
to the one that we were
looking at for cart earlier.
Again, we're looking
at the request rates.
And I've grouped
those by locations.
So I have the four locations.
So US West 2 a, b,
and Central 1 a, b.
But you can see that I'm
only receiving traffic
to the shopfrontend only
in the West regions,
and not in the Central regions,
even though I have pods
running in the Central region.
That means locality load
balancing is working.
And you can configure the
same locality load balancing
for every single service.
So in a sunny day
scenario, that works great.
Everything will go to
its closest endpoint.
But what happens when
there is a failure?
So my load generator is
running in the West region.
What happens if the
West region is down?
I should expect
that load generator
to start sending traffic
to the Central region,
because I have configured
the failover rule as such.
So let's do that.
In order to simulate
that, all I'm going to do
is scale the replicas for the
shopfrontend in the West region
down to 0.
So let's go to the console.
And I'm going to run
the scale command.
And I'm just going to
fix this spelling error.
So all I'm doing is scaling
the shopfrontend deployment
replicas down to 0 in GKE
1, as well as in GKE 2.
These are my two
US West locations.
What that's going to do is
render a failover from US West
2 region to US Central 1.
So we'll wait a few minutes
and see how the charts do.
A few minutes have
passed, and now you
can see that all
of the traffic is
routed to the central servers.
So I have not changed the
load generator's location.
It's still running in US West.
But because of the
failover from US West,
we're now going to Central 1.
The chart to the right is
also showing us error rates
by location.
You can see that
for the same time
that the failover occurred, we
did not experience any errors.
So it was a seamless failover.
And we expect this
to kind of go back
when we change the
replicas back to one.
So let's quickly do that.
So we go back to the console.
All I'm going to do
is rerun that command.
But this time change the replica
to 1 for GKE 2 and for GKE 1,
we'll wait a few minutes.
And now we see that the traffic
has gone back to the US West 2
clusters, and no more traffic
going to the central clusters.
So we're back to our sunny
day state of locality load
balancing.
And again, we did not
experience any errors
throughout this changeover.
So this technique is
also useful if you
want to perform some scheduled
maintenance on a cluster.
You can now manually
and explicitly
drain clusters by scaling
just the replicas down
for any cluster down to
zero, and shifting traffic
over to different clusters as
long as there's capacity there.
And then you can
perform an upgrade
or any kind of maintenance
on those clusters.
The last thing we
want to look at
is observability and
manageability of services.
So for that, let's go
back to the Cloud Console.
And here we're going to
go to Anthos Service Mesh.
When you have Anthos
Service Mesh deployed
on one or more clusters, you
will get this dashboard view.
And this dashboard view
gives you a table view
and a topology view for all
the Anthos enabled services.
So here I have
all of my services
that are running in
multiple clusters,
for example, shopfrontend
is running on four clusters.
I can look at which four
clusters it's running on.
This comes completely
out of the box
without you having to instrument
anything in the application.
If I click on shopfrontend,
I can get further information
about this service.
So I can see inbound
and outbound services
that it's talking to.
I can get the golden signals.
I can look at the metrics
for this particular service.
These are canned
dashboards, again,
that come with every
single service.
So you get these
dashboards out of the box.
So you get requests per
second, error rates, latency
for the three
different percentiles,
the 50th, 95th, and 99th, as
well as request size, response
size, CPU, memory, and disk
for every single service
without having to
instrument anything.
From here, you can also
go to Application Logs.
So I can just click
on Application Logs,
and it will create the
right filters for me.
So I can just look at
the application logs
for the frontend
so I can see that I
have requests going in and out.
I can also look at
traces from here.
So I can just click on traces.
So if I want to look
at request trace,
this is something you do have to
configure in your application.
I can look at the histogram
of my requests coming in.
And then I can click on
an individual request.
And I can obviously look at that
particular trace information.
Again, all of this is part
of the info service mesh.
Furthermore, I can go to
health, and I can create SLOs.
So here I've created
a latency-based SLO
for the frontend service.
And if I open this up,
and if I edit this SLO,
I can just kind of show
you how I created it.
So the first thing is I
picked latency as my metric.
I can either choose
availability or latency.
I can hit Continue.
Here's the actual signal or
the metric that I'm using,
which is the response latencies.
I can see the historical
response latency.
And based on that, I
just picked a value.
So here I could see that there
are some spikes above 1,500
milliseconds.
So I picked one for
1,500 milliseconds.
You give it the
compliance period.
So I'm picking calendar day.
And I'm keeping my goal at 95%.
So 95% of the time
I want my latency
to be 1,500
milliseconds or below
for that particular service.
If I hit Continue, it also
gives me the JSON view
of that particular SLO.
So I can use the SLO API
to create this if I'd like.
And then I just create my SLO.
So for every single
service you can do that.
And I recommend you do that
for every single service.
And you can do that as part
of your CI/CD pipeline.
This is where you'll get your
SLIs and your error budget,
as well as if you've
configured any alerts.
You can create alerts by
just clicking on this.
And you can measure how
exactly your service is being
experienced across the board.
So we typically
recommend at least
creating two SLOs for
every single service,
one for availability
and one for latency.
So you can see whether
your users are actually
able to access your
service, and then
what is their
experience when they
access that particular service.
So that's the end of the demo.
Let's go back to
the presentation.
A few calls to action.
First, hopefully
it's very obvious,
run distributed services.
Never bet your services
on your infrastructure.
By running your service on more
than one Kubernetes cluster,
you've immediately
gained the advantage
of scale and resiliency.
Second, monitor your
distributed services.
Golden signals is a
great place to start.
Somebody gave me this analogy
that when you go to the doctor,
they don't try to diagnose
you for every single disease.
They look at your symptoms,
and then they figure out
exactly what's wrong with you.
So alert on symptoms, not on
every single potential cause.
In the distributed world, there
are thousands and thousands
of signals out there.
And if you want to alert
on every single time
a CPU or memory spikes, you're
going to get overwhelmed.
Lastly, use location
as a benefit.
I see two main
benefits for location,
especially if you're running
multiregional services.
First is you can deliver your
service closer to your user.
And secondly, thinking
about failure domains.
So I think of failure domains
in terms of concentric circles.
For instance, a Kubernetes
cluster is a failure domain.
When a cluster
goes down, it only
takes down the services
that are running
on that cluster A zone
is a failure domain.
If all the clusters in a zone
or the zone itself goes down,
then that zone
cannot serve traffic.
And a region is
a failure domain.
Thinking in those
terms helps you
kind of do figure out how
to do maintenance windows
and scheduled operations
on your infrastructure.
If you want to build
distributed services,
you can go to this link,
bit.ly/run-distributed-services,
or you can pause the video and
scan this QR code that takes
you to the same link.
I thank you for your time.
And enjoy the rest
of the conference.